DOES A SANTA IMPRESSION AND DR.
FAUCI GETS A KIDS BOOK.
ALL IN "SEEN AND UNSEEN."
FIRST THE LIES THAT BIND.
THAT’S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT’S
"ANGLE."
YOU CAN’T SAY THAT TRUMP DIDN’T
WARN EVERYONE ABOUT WHAT WOULD
HAPPEN TO THE SOUTHERN BORDER IF
BIDEN WON THE WHITE HOUSE.
>> JOE BIDEN PLEDGED TO OPEN
BOARDS AND SAID MAYBE WE WILL
RIP DOWN THE WALL.
CAN YOU BELIEVE IT?
OUR OPPONENTS WANT OPEN BORDERS.
IF YOU DON’T HAVE BORDERS YOU
DON’T HAVE A COUNTRY.
>> Laura: MIGRANTS AND HUMAN
TRAFFICICS WERE HAPPY WHEN BIDEN
WON THE WHITE HOUSE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS DOING
EVERYTHING TO KEEP AMERICA FROM
BEING DELUGED WITH CHEAP LABOR
AND CRIMINALS.
BORDER CROSSING SHARPLY DECLINED
AS TRUMP TURNED MIGRANTS AWAY
DUE TO COVID AND SENT ASYLUM
SEEKERS TO WAIT IN MEXICO BEFORE
THEIR HEARINGS.
THE BORDER WALL WOULD HAVE BEEN
FINISHED HAD TRUMP WON.
THE FACT IS BIDEN’S WIN WAS
A HUGE WIN FOR CARTELS AND
ANYONE WHO DIDN’T WANT TO GO
THROUGH LEGAL CHANCE TO GET
HERE.
>> WHAT I WANT FOR MY PEOPLE IS
I WANT PATIENCE TO GET TO THE
U.S.
THEY HAVE A NEW PRESIDENT.
BIDEN WILL HELP ALL OF US.
HE IS GIVING US 100 DAYS TO GET
TO THE U.S.
>> WOULD YOU HAVE DONE THIS WHEN
DONALD TRUMP WAS PRESIDENT?
>> DEFINITELY NOT.
>> DID YOU COME HERE BECAUSE JOE
BIDEN WAS ELECTED PRESIDENT?
>> BASICALLY, BASICALLY.
>> Laura: NOW THE ENTIRE
SITUATION HAS BLOWN UP AT THE
BORDER WITH SO MANY PEOPLE
COMING, THE BORDER PATROL IS
OVERWHELMED AM FACILITIES ARE
OVERFLOW ASKING UNSANITARY.
THERE ARE 15,000 MINORS IN U.S.
CUSTODY SLEEPING ON FLOORS WITH
TINFOIL BLANKETS.
ACCORDING TO THE "WASHINGTON
POST" CHILDREN AS YOUNG AS 5 ARE
SEPARATED FROM PARENTS.
WHEN CONGRESSWOMAN JACKSON LEE
IS WORRIED YOU KNOW IT’S BAD.
>> THE PLAN IS NOT WORKING AT
THIS TIME.
>> Laura: AND IN ARIZONA SHE
SIGNED A LETTER URGING BIDEN TO
TAKE AGGRESSIVE STEPS TO SECURE
OUR BORDER.
FAILING TO REPORT THE SIMPLE
FACTS ABOUT WHAT LAX BORDER
ENFORCEMENT MEANS THE MEDIA ARE
COMPLICIT IN THIS CRISIS.
THEY DEMONIZED TRUMP ON
IMMIGRATION AND NOW THEY ARE
TRYING TO SAVE THEIR OWN
REPUTATION.
CHECK OUT THESE HEADLINES:
IMMIGRATION CHALLENGES MOUNT FOR
BIDEN.
AFTER SEVERAL WEEKS OF WHITE
HOUSE STONE WALLING ABOUT
ALLOWING MEDIA ACCESS, THE
ASSOCIATED PRESS REQUESTED
ACCESS TO BORDER FACILITIES FOR
MORE THAN A MONTH.
THEY ASKED HOMELAND SECURITY
OFFICIALS FOR ACCESS AT LEAST 7
TIMES WITH NO RESPONSE.
EVEN A PRO-AMNESTY CONGRESSMAN
IN TEXAS WAS SO FRUSTRATED HE
RELEASED HIS OWN PHOTOS.
HERE IS ONE OF THEM.
GONE IS THE WIRE FENCING AND
CAGES REPLACED WITH PLEXIGLAS
AND PLASTIC.
THE WHITE HOUSE WANTS TO STALL
OPENING THE CAMPUS TO THE MEDIA
AS LONG AS POSSIBLE.
>> WHEN WILL REPORTERS BE
ALLOWED TO TOUR THE FACILITIES
FOR THE CHILDREN?
>> WE ARE FINALIZING STILTS.
I HOPE TO HAVE AN UPDATE IN THE
COMING DAYS.
WE ARE COMMITTED TO TRANSPARENCY
AND WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THE
MEDIA HAS ACCESS TO THESE SITES.
>> Laura: THERE IS NO WAY TO PUT
THIS EXCEPT THAT’S A TOTAL AND
COMPLETE LIE.
THEY COULD HAVE OPENED THE
STATES ON DAY ONE.
BLUR OUT THE KIDS FACES IF YOU
ARE WORRIED ABOUT PRIVACY.
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION ALLOWED
REPORTERS TO GO INTO THE BORDER
FACILITIES IN TEXAS.
THERE WAS NO REASON TO HIDE
ANYTHING.
IT’S DIFFERENT BECAUSE THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION KNOWS THE
CONDITIONS INSIDE ARE HORRIFIC.
THEY KNOW BIDEN RISKS COMING OFF
AS A TOTAL FRAUD ON THIS ISSUE.
BACK IN JULY 2019, HE WAS THE
GUY RAILING AGAINST TRUMP’S
BORDER DETENTION POLICIES SAYING
TRUMP’S IMMIGRATION POLICIES ARE
AN ASSAULT ON HUMAN DIGNITY.
THAT’S NOT WHO WE ARE.
APPARENTLY PLEXIGLAS IS WHO WE
ARE.
BIDEN’S MEDIA GROUPIES ECHOED
WHAT BIDEN DID IN 2019 AND
REPEATED THE SAME LIES.
THEY ARE ALL CALL WITH THEIR
PANTS DOWN BUT IT’S TOO LATE.
BIDEN STILL THINKS HE CAN LIE
HIS WAY OUT OF HERE.
>> YOU HAVE TO SAY CLEARLY DON’T
COME?
>> YES, WE ARE IN THE PROCESS OF
GETTING SET UP.
IT WON’T TAKE A LONG TIME.
TO BE ABLE TO APPLY FOR ASYLUM
IN PLACE.
DON’T LEAVE YOUR TOWN OR CITY OR
COMMUNITY.
>> Laura: OF COURSE NO ONE
BELIEVES HIM.
NOT THE MIGRANTS FLYING BIDEN
FLAG IN TIJUANA AND SO WHAT?
WE RETURN TO 2019 FOR JUST ONE
OF THE REASONS.
>> IF YOU WANT TO FLEE, YOU
SHOULD COME.
>> Laura: AND THEY DID.
WHAT IS REALLY IMPORTANT NOW,
THIS IS KEY, REPUBLICANS MUST
AVOID MAKING A BAD SITUATION
WORSE.
I AM TALKING REPUBLICANS ON
CAPITOL HILL.
DEMOCRATS WANT TO USE THE CRISIS
THEY ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR TO
FORCE THE HANDS OF GOP MEMBERS
ON IMMIGRATION AMNESTY.
HELL NO, THEY WILL NOT.
YOU CAN’T NEGOTIATE ALREADY
LEGISLATION WITH PEOPLE WHO
DON’T BELIEVE IN BORDERS AND
TELL LIES TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
>> THE BORDER IS CLOSED.
WE ARE EXPELLING FAMILIES AND
SINGLE ADULTS.
>> Laura: THE MAN GOES ON
NATIONAL TV AND SAYS THE BORDER
IS CLOSED.
WHEN WEER PACE TO BREAK A 20
YEAR RECORD FOR THE MOST MIGRANT
CROSSING.
MORE THAN 100,000 PEOPLE IN
FEBRUARY ALONE.
THAT’S TRIPLE NUMBER UNDER TRUMP
IN FEBRUARY 2020.
HE LOST ALL CREDIBILITY.
CONFIDENT THAT THE PRESS CORP
WILL COVER FOR THEM.
THE BIDEN TEAM THINKS THEY CAN
SKATE PAST THIS CRISIS BY
CALLING IT A CHALLENGE.
DEMOCRATS ARE CONFIDENT IN THEIR
MINDS THAT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
WON’T HOLD THEM ACCOUNTABLE FOR
WHAT WILL BE BILLION DOLLARS IN
TAXPAYER MONEY TO FEED, EDUCATE
AND HOUSE AN ENDLESS STREAM OF
MIGRANTS FROM POOR COUNTRIES.
WHEN IS THE LAST TIME YOU HAVE
BEEN IN A HOTEL IN THE PAST
YEAR?
FOR YEARS DEMOCRATS WORKED TO
UNDERMINE ANY OF US WHO CALLED
FOR STRONG BORDER ENFORCEMENT
AND WARNED THAT MIGRANTS WERE
EXPLOITING THE ASYLUM LAWS AND
EMPLOYERS WERE EXPLOITING THE
MIGRANTS AND ATTACKED TRUMP FOR
ANTI-IMMIGRANT FOR DOING THINGS
THAT GOT OUR BORDER UNDER
CONTROL.
IN JUST 8 WEEKS THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION’S POLICIES ARE
DIRECTLY HURTING AMERICANS BY
LOWERING THE ENTRY-LEVEL WAGES
FOR FIRST TIME JOB SEEKERS.
JOBS IN RETAIL, CONSTRUCTION
WORK AND ELDER AND CHILD CARE
WHICH ARE DOMINATED BY FOREIGN
LABOR.
THERE IS NO END IN SIGHT.
DEMOCRATS WILL NEVER FORCE THE
BORDER AGGRESSIVELY.
THEY WILL TALK BUT THAT’S A RUSE
TO SPEED UP CATCH AND RELEASE.
THIS CRISIS WILL CHANGE OUR
COUNTRY FOREVER.
WHAT THE OPEN BORDERS ZEALOTS
WANTED.
THEY CONCEAL INSTEAD OF REVEAL
THEIR TRUE INTENTIONS.
THE ULTIMATE BIDEN LIE.
>> I PROMISE YOU.
I ALWAYS TRY TO DO WHAT I SAY I
AM GOING TO DO.
IF I MAKE A MISTAKE, I WILL TELL
YOU I MADE MISTAKES AND I WILL
TAKE RESPONSIBILITY.
>> Laura: HE IS SO AUTHENTIC
EVEN ON ZOOM.
THE WHOLE TIME THEY WERE TELLING
AMERICANS TO STAY HOME, SLOW THE
SPREAD, MASK UP AND AVOID OTHER
PEOPLE, THESE SAME PEOPLE WERE
ENCOURAGING EVERYONE IN THE REST